what this the playground or empty where
have all the children gone to Late Night
with Conan O'Brien that's right an
audience filled with young uns and
tonight's very special guests from
Newsradio say fully prepped oil experts
why feelings and from CNN financial news
myron kandel with andy brachear and the
back white 4/7 now here's your host hold
on Oh
[Music]
[Music]
all right thank you very much
welcome to the show ladies and someone
we got a we got an amazing show few
people tonight and ladies and gentlemen
you're watching this show home on
television I want you to know right now
we have an audience full of kids give
yourselves a hand good just in this
night if there's gonna be fun Andy on me
all night long all it's it's what we've
been aiming for that's what we've been
hard these four years we've been on
that's right now kids I want to start
off by asking a quick question who read
the newspaper today y'all read the news
right whether you're gonna love this
this was in the news today I'm sure you
read it a a bank did you hear this a
bank repossessed Oh J Simpson's car to
help pay off his debts that really
happened yeah yeah and and today why
I'll tell you why today he was spotted
hitchhiking really slowly with Al
cowlings did you hear that
[Applause]
you like that one now alright I got a
new one I don't have you heard this but
according to a new survey kids
Washington DC is the worst place to
raise a family that's right yeah however
it's still the best place to raise
illegal campaign contributions
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I could tell some of you were
really angry about that story finally
last thing I'll mention before we get
started kids Barbra Streisand you all
know her from Yentl right yeah Barbra
Streisand has asked the e networks
gossip show not to call her Babs anymore
that's right she does not want to be
called Babs anymore yeah the only
problem is now they've started calling
her poopy head see I saved the best for
last I always end on poopy head all
right you guys still like that all right
we're gonna talk about who's on
tonight's show kids this is really
exciting we have from News Radio Dave
Foley's with us isn't that great we also
have we also have reptile expert this
guy is going to bring a lot of reptiles
out here really weird animals clyde
peelings on the show
[Applause]
and then kids I saved the best for last
that's right kids listen to who's on the
show at the end of the program tonight
from CNN financial news myron kandel
this is so great and of course Max
Weinberg
and he's Max Weinberg 7 give it to him
kids it's not man we got a we got a lot
to talk about here Andy isn't this nice
we got all these kids here it's very
exciting it's so much more exciting
normally we have adults and adults are
no good yeah adults our beds are alright
kids are great kids are the best and
that's why we have an audience honey can
smell pandering from a mile away
they're like Andy that was so low no I'm
really excited about the show tonight we
have all these kids in the audience and
they're very special it's it's actually
it's a nice group of kids to you at home
watching probably haven't been able to
notice in particular different kids in
the audience but some of these kids look
like real-life adult celebrities here's
the first one she looks like a real-life
adult celebrity doesn't she look like
Claire Danes huh we also have you got to
see this next kid look at this kid right
here he's the spitting image of Emilio
Estevez right there
now let's find this next kid where's
this next kid I want to see you there
okay look this kid looks so much like
Lila Kenzel from that about you yes you
do not at all happy about it now we
found a bunch of kids this is amazing a
whole row of kids look at these kids
right here don't they look exactly like
the Spice Girls right there
[Applause]
sporty spice and then finally kit look
at this last kid everybody we find he
looks like gene Shalit doesn't he look
so much like gene Shalit there's
medication you can take for that all
right now kids kids everyone settled
down because there's kids were over here
talk show talk show going on there's
something very important to talk about
yes
we've lost the kids in the audience
already we may still have someone at
home but you know we have these kids
seem pretty nice and well-behaved
don't they they sure do that they seem
for the most part pretty well behaved
mm-hmm but actually we're a little
worried that maybe just maybe some kid
might misbehave that's what I was
thinking I was thinking what do we have
any sort of plan in case somebody does
sort of start acting bad and you know
getting too loud or something that's
right we do well we have it we do have a
plan Andy I'm glad you asked if a kid
misbehaves tonight in the audience and I
don't think it's gonna happen because
there's such nice kids
but if a kid does misbehave we're gonna
send that kid to knotty land that's
right you're gonna have to go to knotty
land and kids let me tell you something
you do not want to go to knotty land I
don't want to send you there but I might
have to take a look at knotty lands
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you don't want to go there kids kids
believe me it looks kind of fun but
balloons candy we're doing you a huge
favor yeah I spent like about ten
minutes there and I about went nuts yeah
he went crazy all right now we got to
talk for a second kids we wanted the
show to beat we want it because we have
kids here tonight we wanted it to be a
fun show so we have a very special
surprise we wanted a big-time celebrity
to come on the show and say hi to all
the kids and this is someone who we've
never had on the show before kids we got
Dustin Hoffman tonight isn't that
amazing Dustin Hoffman's gonna be here
that's right that's right
ratso Rizzo this is really cool yeah
that's exciting
and now kids you have a choice we want
this to be a special show you can either
have Dustin Hoffman come out as himself
or he can come out dressed as Snoopy now
what do you want you want me
okay okay okay all right kids you asked
for it
here he is come on out Dustin Hoffman as
Snoopy everybody come on out here Dustin
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Dustin I just want to say it's a
it's a real treat having you on the show
you've done some amazing work as an
actor and thanks very much for stopping
by mm-hmm all right very good
Dustin off and everybody give him a hand
[Applause]
[Music]
now see him without it oh oh he's gone
I'm sorry we can't do that you want to
see them without it
[Applause]
kids he just got on a bus he's gone I'm
sorry he's gone wait a minute these kids
these kids are so much sharper than I
thought the whole section is like yeah
that's that's not me look see more than
this now that's a suit ah
let's see without the suit I don't want
to send you to knotty land miss but I
will if I ask you all right now kids
we've had some fun up front we're just
gonna say we have but let's get down now
to some serious business everybody all
right now kids I asked upfront if you
read the newspapers and I know you do
and you know the biggest news these days
continues to be the budget agreement
worked out last week by Congress
now everyone agrees that the big winner
seems to be the president who won major
concessions in several key areas and
tonight I thought we'd talk to the man
himself and find out how he accomplished
all this so ladies and gentlemen kids
boys and girls please welcome live via
satellite President Bill Clinton all
right welcome mr. president good to have
you now let's get right to it now sir
one of your most surprising victories
last week came in the battle over
welfare reform how did you manage to get
so much sir what are you doing
look at me kids I'm a fish
all right mr. president mr. president I
really don't think you need to do that
okay I don't do it
Conan oh man that was a stinky no sir
don't do that that's at me a little man
I got away with the youngins now sir
please you're the President of the
United States now all right aren't I
excuse me Conan Kent cannot talk
seriously for a moment oh yeah all right
I'd like to address this to the young
people in the audience then kids you are
this country's future and nothing is as
important to your own future as the
ability to read now I just finished
reading the book myself it was called
40-yard dash to the bathroom wasn't
written by a willy make it illustrated
by Betty Lou that was great sir that was
he didn't make it by the way yeah
sure he didn't yeah sir can we get back
to the budget Conan he made that noise
it wasn't let me bring out a buddy of
mine kids you're gonna love this
somebody I'm sure he'll see that oh it's
it's vice president al gore kids yeah
[Music]
what happened there man not Gor man
Gore's like going to Gore's like bath
time you know what I mean okay alright
alright the dude I'm talking about kids
is always getting into trouble but then
he always manages to come out on top get
on out here buddy
[Applause]
hey there are scooby-doo good to see ya
come on kids you know the words sing
along
Scooby dooby doo where are you we got
some work to do
that's great sir yeah mr. president mr.
president I think we should wrap this up
now okay but first man how about a
little scuba snack for my buddy
all right well I just happen to be I
have a Scooby Snack right here so give
it a Scooby yeah there you go there you
go how's that Scooby there you go all
right
now one for me it's dog food
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right folks we're gonna take a break
we'll be right back we'll see all right
everybody we are back now before we go
on I wanted to warn I wanted to warn all
the kids in the studio right now about a
very scary monster that lives right here
in the NBC building now let me let me
tell you about him let me tell you by
kids he's called the board a monster
because he loves to eat people who
aren't having any fun and you know what
that means tell me what that means Andy
well that means that if you kids sort of
if you'd start getting bored or you
start getting too quiet then the monster
will come and he'll try and get us he'll
try and eat us all that's right Andy's
not kidding about this and kids if the
board of monster comes there's only one
way to get him to leave us alone and
that's to laugh and clap as loud as you
can so that he knows we're not really
bored he hears that and then he goes
away and then oh no kids the board of
mon-sol alarm is going on
the border monsters outside he's in the
roar
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
wait kids that works he went away good
for you that was very good nice work
kids
yeah by the way kids I just want you to
know the board of monsters attack this
show many times no many many times so
we're free now oh man welcome to the
show oh I think you're gonna hi hi Dave
[Music]
[Applause]
it's nice isn't it it's a nice place it
is yeah they smell for you you don't
have kids yeah this is your hell for you
it's just like being home yeah I have
actually a hundred and fifty children
all right now eight kids settle down
we're gonna talk to Dave Foley for a bit
I'm not gonna take very long no right
now first of all what we're gonna do yes
I went to Africa I I flew to to Zimbabwe
Africa and flew into her on them and
then from there went on to spend
Christmas at Victoria Falls Victoria
Falls it yeah it's very beautiful yeah
it is
[Applause]
the boring monster
[Applause]
oh man that was a close one
that was a close call
okay wait a minute
they didn't even give you a child oh I
think it was very entertaining when you
were talking about you don't think we
could do now hey kids we're gonna play a
game right now hold it kids but you have
to be quiet first or you don't play the
game all right now settle down now this
is a game we're gonna play using you
kids in the audience
all right that's right now Dave I don't
know if you can use this we can use our
advanced computer technology to look
into the future and see what these kids
are going to look like when they get old
that's right we're gonna show you kids
we're gonna show you kids what you're
gonna look like when you're old for
example let's look at this kid right
here listen listen areas look like when
he's old blah
[Applause]
that's right now look at this girl right
here let's see what she's gonna look
like her eyes are gonna go look at this
little girl right here what is she gonna
look like
[Applause]
that's terrible how about this boy right
here let's see what he's gonna look like
oh let's see what this boy is gonna look
like I'm curious Dave aren't you and
hold it let's hear what this kid's gonna
look like right here she wants it let's
see right now hey wait a minute you
asked for it this kid right here this
kid right here
all right kids we hope you enjoyed that
we're gonna give you all classes of
water and we'll be right back after this
break Dave Foley thank you very much
Dave
all right now kids so far we've been
having a good time here tonight but I do
have to stress once again as nice as
everyone's been here if someone starts
to misbehave I don't want to do it but
we're gonna have to take them to knotty
land that's right kids I know it seems
it seems okay to you but knotty land is
not a nice place take another look at
knotty land kids now we're gonna go
shopping at the Disney Store but you can
only spend $500 all right
spend as much money as you want
[Applause]
kids you don't want to be there chili
yeah chili I know boy every time I see
that I get a chill all right ladies and
gentlemen a couple of kids showed up
early today most kids showed up from
their summer camp they came right from
summer camp to the show today but a
bunch of the kids showed up early so I
decided to give them a tour of NBC and
it was a lot of fun the kids are real
sweet we had a good time take a look at
what happened you know we're gonna do
today I'm gonna give you guys a tour of
NBC that's the National Broadcasting
Corporation isn't that nice now if any
kids act unruly or misbehave you're
gonna have to get a tour of Fox there's
me with Richard Lewis isn't he really
fun he's a really neurotic comic isn't
he don't you think he's really neurotic
there I am with Al Roker you know Al
Roker you saw him in a movie there's an
Al Roker movie was he the star of the
movie
[Music]
this is where we do the show this is Liz
everyone say hi Liz
see these buttons right there kids it
doesn't look like it but they're made of
candy and this man eats them throughout
the whole show look at that isn't that
amazing and when he's done nobody's done
eating them that's when we know the show
is over hey guys who wants to touch the
asbestos ceiling tile you guys will be
the first people to see my dressing room
isn't that cool
except for two with your rock that's
some fun let's put on your jacket this
is what I do okay all right now your
this is what I do every night and then I
get ready to do the show all right and
then I wring my hands go like this go oh
me oh my oh what am I gonna do all right
very nice now you're ready for the do
the show what's green and walks through
walls Casper the Friendly pickle
then you come back in your dressing room
you're gonna ask him right now how was
the show and everyone go oh it was great
it was great it was great even though
you know it wasn't okay let's try it
how's the show see that's what it's like
in here after the show isn't that cool
yeah say I didn't screw anything up and
all of you go oh no no no you're a
genius you're a genius
[Music]
see now you guys are all working in
television now guys look over here this
is my hero and I think your hero - lets
all say his name together Robert Stack
wait a minute you kids have nightmares
about Robert yeah what [ __ ] how many
kids here have nightmares about Robert
Stack oh really and you wake up in the
middle of the night and your mother has
to come in the room and tell you don't
worry there's no Robert Stack underneath
the bed hey kids it's Don Pardo everyone
say hi Don Pardo
[Applause]
hey dawn do us a favor give him up it's
Saturday Night Live give me it
Saturday night long now kids let me
explain this to you the interns do not
get paid but they have to do whatever we
say
they have to do whatever we say who
wants to eat some food take turns do our
bidding say we want McDonald's get us
mcdonalds or no college credit no codes
credit say you must go and you must go
and you must go hey look kids it's Andy
so Andy you just get into work huh yes
hey kids what time is it that's right
it's 4 o'clock yes 4 o'clock get them
kids go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you okay now yeah all right well we had
a good time we're gonna take a little
break right now but hang on to your
seats we'll be right back oh my god
conan night babies couple of gifts here
look how big these are these are
amphibians we're gonna look at three
classes of animals today we hold these
right up to camera first because these
are the biggest frogs I think in the war
are they frog well you have the Frog I
have the toad this is a giant toad
called a giant marine toad from South
America right this is an African
bullfrog both of these get quite large
I've seen both of them almost platter
size look how big this is and can you
eat these I think I eat one right now
[Music]
now I should tell you that all
amphibians have poisonous skin oh my god
really
berries are poisonous well why is he
looking he's getting really mad what's
he doing he's just squirming trying to
get okay oh that's right
oh this animal especially has large
glands here which exude a poison yeah if
a dog were to grab this it would be very
distasteful and Todd shoots poison out
of where doesn't shoot poison but it it
exudes the poison from these glands and
that would probably teach the dog a
lesson he probably wouldn't do it the
second time that's really cool but if
someone's bothering it it can just make
poison kind of come out of it and get
all over the place right right oh these
are very good what else you got for us
okay let me get rid of these I should
point out that amphibians worldwide are
disappearing and oh man look at this
what is this this this belongs to an
entirely different class this is a
mammal and it comes from Mexico and
South America Central America it's
called a quwata Mundi a quwata Mundi
okay and we bring him over here can we
get him on the desk this is Whitney Han
from Catoctin zoo and Thurmond Maryland
and she's raised this animal it's a by
winning how are you oh very inquisitive
animals here constantly twitching the
nose 45 degrees looking for something to
eat look at that look at his nose you
often times see these going across the
bluff or something and if if you'll help
me Conan hi and Andy well-well get in
line here and we'll create a what are we
gonna do here and and we'll see if you
can get this inquisitive animal to go
across our shoulders we have ended and
what do we do now she's going to put the
quarter Mundi on Andy uh and then she's
going to get over in the other side
yeah stand up now I stand up I killed it
oh it's fine it's fine everybody all
these kids are worried can it can it
right on top of me is it does it know
how to do Oh
Oh get can the kids see it too is that
all right if I hold on to it so I take
it over to see some kids all right there
oh it's getting scared - scared - scared
huh
it got weighed it got too scared it got
too scared I guess right he's yeah he's
a little bit nervous with all the knife
I think some of the kids here are shy
sometimes right you know no I guess they
yelled no wait I have a question
why am i all wet right now stage fright
[Applause]
okay
well it wasn't the animal it was me what
else we gotta go to get a little we got
about a minute left okay let's put the
Quan last why go around back and Andy if
you'd give me a hand here we'll take
this fellow out this is a baby Python
from Southeast Asia Python kids wait
everybody loves babies let's let's get
this out of the way right now you put it
all together
[Applause]
when they drink another your faders
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god wait this is a Burmese python
to say one of the giant snakes they get
25 cents a baby well I was putting you
on it oh you're joking yeah when it
passes it's about 18 20 inches long it
grows very quickly the first three or
four years this snake could conceivably
be only four years old I think it's
actually a little older I have a
question
would this be a good pet would kids like
this for a pet something to people
breeding these for the pet trade these
days you know what I'd like to see I'd
like to see this snake fight the board
of monster at some point wouldn't that
be cool a fight that's not gonna happen
all right now kids we're gonna take a
little break what's it doing huh huh all
right we're gonna take a little break
and as we go away to commercial I'm
going to find out what kids need to go
to the bathroom raise your hand and me
and the snake will take you all right
we'll be right back folks we'll stick
around and take some kids all right
we're back everybody now kids we got a
surprise for you right now you kids like
surprises don't you well guess what kids
right now we've got a parade of sick
exotic birds Wow a sick exotic bird
parade and here they come this is gonna
be great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright that was pretty cool huh
those were some sick exotic bird yeah
that's birds were pretty sick we'll take
a break we'll be right back kids
okay now Myron thanks very much for
coming now a lot of kids want to know
just how CNN got started they want to
know what's it like working on a 24-hour
foreign news program and basically also
how do you manage a financial news
network I mean how do you do that kind
of a show let's talk about that very
easily
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean he's right outside ain't it quick
at the door the door shut
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we did yeah
that was great that started very early
kids were safe now that the monsters
gone good job everybody good job now
listen I know kids I'll get to your
questions now first of all people want
to know first of all let's talk about
this the bull market has been going on
now for fifteen years a lot of people
want to know is this gonna just continue
well beau market started in August 1982
and with a couple of interruptions it's
it's continued to this day and it looks
like it's got some more steam behind it
so we can see it keep going but how
could a bull market go on for that long
whatever arise that long as kids know
there has to be a fall well there are
pull backs which we've had and you know
the opposite of a bow market that's
right
bear market a bear market kids know that
that's right they do they were about to
say it with you but they thought it was
impolite yeah so my question is this do
you think at some point we're headed for
a big crash or you think we're fine for
the long haul I think we're not going to
see a crash anytime soon this economy is
doing very well you know very well that
inflation is low the economy is
moderated interest rates are going down
it's a very unemployment is very low
it's really a good scene in the US
economy these days and that's why Wall
Street is benefiting hey kids Wall
Street is benefiting isn't that great
now you actually you kids don't know
this but but Myron here predicted the
bull market now a lot of people must be
looking to you for tips do you give
stock tips ever never give stock tips
but I did write a book fifteen years ago
I wrote a book that said how to cash in
on the coming stock market boom and that
boom started a few months later after
the book came out so it's a good book
everyone here should read that book yeah
it's a little old by now and the fact is
you're gonna ask me whether I took my
own advice did you I mean did you did
you are you a rich man I'm still working
for a living okay listen
Myron you've been very helpful so far
but I think what you need to do is
something that might get the kids
interested so maybe you could do a
little crazy dance when you kids like to
see Myron do a crazy dance
[Applause]
[Music]
hey that was great we do that on the
street all the time
what do you mean boo that was he did a
rabbit for you myron kandel just did a
rabbit dance that's right that was
incredible thank you very much you know
it might help actually if you'd put this
on wouldn't you like to see my Rijn
Kandel become an elephant huh
put that on the kids are gonna love that
you see there you go thank you very much
you know Conan yeah on Wall Street we
have Bose we have bears we never had an
elephant until today Myron I want to
mention CNN and CNN's financial news
you're doing those shows but also as the
kids know you do moneyline with Lou
Dobbs weeknights at 7:00 right it was a
real pleasure having you on the program
my pleasure to be here
and I hope my grandchildren I have three
grandsons
I hope they can stay up late enough to
watch this show well this show all along
was meant for them let's put it that way
let's go out and I think Myron and I
should both do his dance on the way out
to the music of the night you want to
thank our guests we want to thank an
amazing audience we had here today whom
you want to invite all the kids to come
down now have cupcakes ice cream and
play with silly string
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]